this division is so putrid until i've
now had to pivot from my position that
division winners
should get home games i'm okay with
division winners
getting
uh into the playoffs
i think the division should get you in
the playoffs even like look if it's a
bad division it happens if you win the
division though you should be rewarded
by getting into the playoffs that should
punch your ticket to the postseason but
the home game should go to the team
with the better record
and if you're a top two or three seed
the chances the chances are swim that a
five or six seed is gonna have a better
record than you chances are typically
slim but if you're the fourth seed and
the five seed has a better record
there's no way the five c should be
going on the road to play a six and ten
or seven and nine dallas cowboys team
and seven and nine if they finish seven
and nine that'd be miraculous the way
this team looks
so just to be clear you think a team
that makes the playoffs with a losing
record should go you should make the
playoffs but go on the road no matter on
the road yeah don't take don't take the
playoff spot away from a division winner
take the home but it has to be losing
but but how about if one team is nine
and seven no it just goes by eleven and
five
it goes by c same thing eleven and five
so all right eleven and five you have a
better record than the nine and seven
division winner then you should get i
like that eleven and five the first one
i like the second one i don't like so i
like the scenario well you can't you
can't you can't adjust it every year
whether they have a loser i know that's
what i'm gonna leave
that's why i'm gonna keep it the same
that's why i'm gonna keep it the same
because okay i agree with you like if
you're seven and nine or six and ten and
you play in a bad division it's a
cyclical thing it's not gonna happen
every year all right you won your
division there's a reward in that even
if the division is weak yes get into the
playoffs i got no issue with it
and if you're six and ten no you
shouldn't be playing at home go on the
road
but i don't like getting into well we
were nine and seven
uh y'all were ten and six we won our
division but since you were ten and six
i gotta go on a roll but because that
opens up too many things like maybe that
year i played in a brutal division and
nine and seven is actually equal to if
not better than your 10-6 so why am i
going on the road to play you and you
play in the weak division so
i i just want to lose leave it at
losing teams should not play home games
home playoff games i'll leave it at that
and i'm with you you go further
you no longer have my support
yeah i think the worst thing going back
to my original question though uh how we
started this cowboys conversation which
is do you derive any pleasure
um from the cowboys painting no
um no i don't
well not only not only is the answer no
for me as well because i know it's fun
because cowboys fans are always you know
insufferable which a lot of they're not
alone a lot of fans can be insufferable
a lot of fan bases can be insufferable
but there's a particular boston type of
i swear yeah exactly
there's a peculiar type of of
insufferability
associated with cowboys fans however
um i i think it's i think it's a bad
look for the sport and it's a bad look
for the league to have
i think they're the most valuable maybe
washington is number one but they're up
there um
to have
your marquee franchise your marquee
brand
be suck be such so poor so porous so
putrid like it's just it's just not a
good look for the league i think the
league is better when the cowboys are
good enough to hate the love them or
hate them comes from when they are on
top i just can't point you you know you
don't hate a loser you're like a loser
you just disregard it's like they're not
even relevant like we're talking about
them because they played last night
honestly that's the only reason i'm
talking about the cowboys because they
played last night i have no like and so
now you know we need something to talk
about so let's talk about a team that
got curved stumped uh by the arizona
cardinals last night in their own
stadium but generally speaking they're
becoming irrelevant and so that's why i
say the last thing i want me to go back
in circles but the last thing you need
to do is make a change the one position
that you know you have going for you
which is quarterback so that's all i
have to say about the cowboys
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports